Коли минулого польський уряд вирішив заборонити
аборти і навіть карати за це ув’язненням -
сотні людей вийшли на протести не лише у Польщі,
а й у Брюсселі. Тоді офіційна Варшава
відмовилась від своїх планів.
Це стало першою ластівкою для подальших протестів, зокрема, тих,
що прокотилися Польщею останніми місяцями.
Тепер поляки обурились через законопроект, який надасть
міністру юстиції право призначати
і звільняти суддів Верховного Суду.
Цього Єврокомісія вже не могла стерпіти - і заявила,
що вперше в історії ЄС застосує проти Варшави
так званий "правовий механізм"
за порушення демократичних прав.
Для Польщі це означатиме, зокрема, позбавлення права голосу в ЄС
та зменшення дотацій від Євросоюзу.
Ми все ще простягуємо руку польському уряду та сподіваємось на конструктивний діалог.
Але водночас ми пильно стежимо за подіями у Польщі.
І реагуватимемо відповідним чином.
Експерти ж вважають - і східноєвропейські країни,
і ЄС недооцінили ті зусилля,
які були необхідними для вступу в Євросоюз.
Це було не так легко, як ми сподівались. І Захід, і решта Європи
повинні розпочати дійсно фундаментальну розмову
про те,  що означають ті цінності, які ми обстоюємо,
і наскільки вони для нас важливі.
Тим часом правозахисники закликають Єврокомісію
таки застосувати механізми покарання Польщі.
На їхню думку. це буде корисно
як для майбутньому Євросоюзу, так і для польського народу.
Ми вже бачили, як Єврокомісія змовчала у ситуації з Угорщиною.
Якщо Брюссель і надалі мовчатиме у випадку Польщі,
це може призвести до катастрофи у всьому ЄС.
Коли Польща приєдалась до ЄС у дві тисячі четвертому році,
Варшава з ентузіазмом сприйняла
європейські цінності.Тепер же
польський уряд може першим серед країн-членів ЄС наразитися
на санкції за порушення тих самих принципів.